let's skip through this give me some
fake booze next time I'm gonna do this
alright so I finished Jessica Jones
season two because I know a heck of a
lot of commenters were telling me on
actually not only my review of the first
three episodes of Jessica Jones which
was explicitly labeled a review of only
the first three episodes but also my
more recent video about what I think is
the not so bright future of Marvel
Netflix that I need to not run my mouth
until I've seen the whole season well
I've seen the whole season so you can
all shut up and listen to me [ __ ] but
look before I get into all that because
obviously I'm a surly drunk clearly this
was not as bad as I feared
based off the trailers and honestly the
first three episodes it did get better
and then it got worse again basically
there's a chunk in the middle that
worked really well for me and in a
surprising way I'm gonna get into
spoilers if you haven't figured that out
already so when we get the twist of
Jessica's mother being alive and kind of
sort of being the villain of the season
my first initial reaction was oh you
have got to be kidding me
that I just thought that was the
stupidest thing that they could possibly
have thought to do and then the very
next episode they devoted the entire
episode to giving full context to what
happened to her why she was away for a
while why she would have actually
voluntarily taken herself away from
Jessica even after trying to get in
touch with her and where Jessica herself
was at the time of all of this and
that's probably my favorite episode of
the season cuz it gets really a the
heart of the characters and the
consequences of what they do and
why they're doing what they're doing and
it sold me on an idea I rejected like
initially and harshly it sold me on it
now it didn't suddenly make the entire
season good it just meant that this
massive hole that the twist had dug just
got filled in and smoothed over and then
honestly the next few episodes focusing
on Jessica you know trying to deal with
her mother were pretty good I would say
up until now but the other mother ends
up in jail then it starts to waver then
her mother breaks out and then I didn't
care it the last two episodes the light
the last episode especially was just a
sea of nothing and I mean let me figure
out the other things positive that I can
say because because as tends to happen I
know from experience at this point once
I start talking negatives that's where
my brain is gonna stay I I think the the
MVP for the supporting cast is gonna be
Malcolm I liked Malcolm in the first
season I really like him in this eye and
he makes a ton of sense to me I like you
know the emphasis on how important it is
for him to keep busy cuz it's how he
stays out of trouble to the best that
he's able to I mean yeah I get that
so and actually the the guy who was the
super in Jessica's building didn't like
him at first he grew up me and his
relationship with Jessica grew on me he
had one moment in particular where
they're in Jessica's apartment Jessica
kind of I was gonna say she throws
herself at him she doesn't really but
she starts to try and unbuckle his pants
he kind of goes whoa whoa whoa whoa and
he says this is not normal she's like
yeah I know I'm not normally and he's he
really emphasized like no not you this
what you're doing right now this is not
normal and that was a really cool moment
somewhat undercut a little bit later
when they
she did get it on in his apartment and
she was clearly distraught and somehow
he thought it was okay and healthy this
time yeah but overall I liked him his
kid was annoying but is the the kid
fulfilled his plot function so if that
worked well enough Jessica's mother was
well performed for what was required of
her we'll go with that very specific
phrase Jessica herself was good not
great I think I mean I'm just gonna have
to start getting to the negatives I mean
the main thing is this this season did
not have the focus of the previous
season because the previous season
everything circled around Jessica her
damage specifically the damage from
kilgrave so everything circled her and
him and then their connection their
relationship and and what he did to her
everything came back to that this time
not not so much the while I I can say
that Jessica's whole thing with her
mother was the the overall sort of point
and heart of the of the season not
everything kept coming back to it and
maybe they're thinking oh well we'll
branch out and one night except that a
good strong focus for most of the first
season it even that had a couple of
episodes towards the end that were more
or less filler and they were the weakest
part of that of that season but they the
focus was such a big part of why the
first season was great and it's just not
here I think nobody embodies that better
than Hogarth
I like Hogarth as a character but there
is no point to her storyline and it's
actually not even a bad storyline she
portrays her fears or concerns about
everything she's going through really
well actually it's even pretty
well written but it doesn't contribute
to anything it doesn't tie back into
what's going on with Jessica or just his
mother or even what's going on with
Trish or any of it
it's Hogarth was in the first season
because she had specific plot functions
to contribute she's in this season
because she was in that season what she
does in this season does not actively
contribute to the story really at all
and that's not even restricted to
recurring characters because we've got
somebody like Price who was stupid like
he he set off a couple of plot points
but it was totally possible to not have
to come up with this idiot
of a character who goes on about how
professional of a pea I he is but who
can't seem to do any degree of decent
investigation and then tries to murder a
woman like what the know this guy was
dumb and stupid and actually somebody
commented in one of my on one of my
earlier videos that they called this
season an idiot plot and if that's not a
term you're familiar with it's a plot
that the narrative only moves forward
because people are acting like idiots
and if people stopped and acted rashly
you know rationally and just thought
about what they did instead of doing
something really dumb this story
wouldn't happen the way it does the only
way it can happen is if people like
stupid I actually that's a slight
overstep to apply that to Jessica Jones
season two but I will say I understood
why this commenter accused it of being
bad there's a lot of stuff that goes on
that is just characters acting really
really dumb and I'm not saying you can
never have characters act stupidly or
foolishly but when it's almost all of
them and it seems to be the only way
that any of the plots move forward
that's a problem you don't have to have
four characters who never make mistakes
but when when it seems like every
character is making mistakes that that
doesn't work so I mean you know hogarth
is making stupid decisions in terms of
you know the vulnerability she opens up
to herself with this woman that she
doesn't even know again understandable
but she's acting dumb for that reason
price literally never does anything
smart the entire time he's on screen
he's a friggin idiot Trish's mom has a
number of stupid moments including
contributing to another thing that was
overused in this season which is the the
magical expositional news network always
the right broadcast on at the right time
so the correct characters here exactly
that headline yay and Trish's mom got to
factoring to that so that double
annoyance right there but if we really
want to talk about characters acting
like idiots Trish I liked Trish and the
first season I liked her dynamic with
Jessica I thought she was a really
positive influence on the show I kind of
hated her in this first of all she's
dealing with threads left over from what
was the least interesting plotline in
the first season which was the whole
enhancement inhaler thing which wasn't
interesting then why did they think that
was a plotline worth continuing a thread
worth picking up and then having her get
this obsession a mad jealousy that you
know Jessica has powers and I don't and
they just they overcook like there could
have been something there there's
there's an honesty to the idea that she
is jealous of Jessica and what Jessica
can do but the degree that they pushed
it to and I don't care if they tried to
justify it with drug withdrawal but the
degree that they pushed it to just
breaks the character to the point that
one of two things happens either I don't
buy it which makes it bad writing or I
buy it and now hater which ruins the
characters so pick your poison either
way it's screwed up coming back to
Jessica's mom I had given you know that
selective praise of her as far as the
performance goes but
she acts really dumb too she does
admittedly have the excuse of being
crazy so she's got that going for her so
I guess what's everybody else's excuse
you know we had kilgrave back for one
episode which I liked but also was
unnecessary and very much a gimmick but
I did still enjoy I'll admit to that I'm
not above you know giving into a bit of
fanservice I liked that
his showing up was triggered by Jessica
taking a life I thought that was a good
trigger because it was the thing it was
the thing that he told her to do that
broke his spell over her you know even
prior to the first season so that makes
sense I like yeah I mean I just like
having David Tennant back in this part
he's really good at it so that that
worry and I mean in general I kind of
like these character that's just in your
head think especially it was kind of an
antagonistic relationship I enjoy that
as a narrative device as a character
piece as a trope I just I kind of like
that I love second season a Farscape
with with Harvey in Crichton's head I
love that stuff but ultimately it it
didn't mean anything it was just there I
do really like to note he left on which
was just I'll be here if you need me I'm
like okay that's kinda cool and all that
but ultimately it didn't serve any point
it didn't move anything forward and it
didn't really feed into the themes of
the season at least what I thought the
theme of the season was because it seems
to be doing this whole thing with you
know family and the impact of your past
and being able to live with that cope
with that and all that stuff and kill
great he doesn't build on those family
themes the same way his deal was a whole
other deal and so shoving him in there
isn't elevating what it seems like the
show's trying to do maybe that's not
what the show was trying to do the show
seemed really confused because
that the whole plot with Jessica and her
mother honestly could have probably made
for really good eight you know what
probably not even eight probably six
episodes of television really tight
really focused could have been really
good but it wasn't
it's meandering and slow to kick off
when it's the central focus for kind of
the middle I don't know four or five
episodes or so it does pretty well and
but then it starts meandering again and
then ends in a conclusion that's just
weird there was a line that her mother
had that I literally burst out laughing
I'm pretty sure this was the last
episode where Jessica's like you know I
tried calming you I tried you know I
tried capturing you and her mother goes
you didn't try joining me I'm like can't
kill II just dubbing Darth Vader join me
and we will rule the galaxy like what
what is this and it just you know I kind
of gave her mother a pass when I said
she's crazy except her crazy is just she
has what I tend to term plot convenient
itis which is a medical or mental
condition that kicks in every time you
needed to impact the plot and otherwise
goes away and she's got that in spades
you want another example Cosima had that
over a northen orphan black got sick
whenever it was uh it would move the
plot along and then otherwise was fine
so yeah this again to come back to what
I said when I started this is not awful
there's some decent stuff in here and
it's not as bad as I was afraid it was
gonna be it's better than Iron Fist I
can't say whether or not it's better
than The Punisher cuz I didn't finish
the Punisher and I've heard you know
very mixed things about that but a
Punisher didn't grip me I didn't finish
it so I can't tell you I would I would
rewatch this again before I would watch
Iron Fist again before I would watch the
defenders again I put it close to Luke
Cage first season Luke Cage
don't know which one I would rank higher
because they both have significant
chunks that aren't great Luke Cage
they're more confined to the back end
Jessica Jones they're more spread around
but regardless of this not being as bad
as I was afraid it was gonna be it's a
massive step down from the first season
which came in with a really clear
distinct mission and point and goal and
executed it almost to perfection like I
said little flabby few too many episodes
but it it had the focus that made it so
strong that this season just doesn't
have at all
so that that's it that's just good Jones
season 2 and I mean and they set up crap
with Trish you know I'm sure to become
Hellcat which I doubt we are ever gonna
see you can see my other video on
Netflix to find out why I don't think
we're ever gonna see that but just good
Jo season 2 did you get through the
whole thing what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do like like can
subscribe and I've got a patreon and
Twitter and a P o box and you can buy
t-shirt and links for all this stuff and
more is down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]